et du coup mais moi j'étais atteignable
donc tout le monde venait me faire des
photos avec moi pour me demander Cyril
et les commandes dans la vie etc des
photos comme ça au bout d'un moment il
est intrigué que tout le monde vient de
me voir faire des photos et du coup il a
demandé à la garde du corps de venir me
chercher
des litiges etc et comme ça il m'a
regardé et puis il m'a fait genre enfin
j'ai gros je suis resté une minute
planté devant lui puis au non j'ai
compris qu'il fallait que je peux venir
du grand écran 7e
de Cannes
comme toi
il me dégoûte ce mec là chez lui cet
après-midi au téléphone il dit que c'est
pas du tout je suis votre coach de vie
non non mais je te jure alors bah tu es
conseillé tu peux te ou je pense
en fait plus vieillit plus l'âge de ses
conquêtes 10 minutes donc au début
c'était 25 24 23 lundi
la question qu'il faut se poser pardon
mais est-ce qu'elle serait allé avec lui
si c'était pas Léonardo Dicaprio mais
est-ce que ta meuf elle sera avec toi
c'était pas gagné
mais arrête de dire des conneries j'ai
vu ta meuf c'est un avion tu crois
qu'elle sera avec toi
j'ai un peu tu me dis avec ma première
femme j'avais 10 ans d'écart avec ma
deuxième femme 20 et puis maintenant ma
troisième femme 30 ah voilà voilà ça se
termina l'histoire
ça fait quoi ça fait deux gars comme ça
je vous présenterai pas ma femme elle a
l'air dégourdi
toi ça choque là oh ça me choque bah il
fait ce qu'il veut s'il veut pécho des
meufs qui le fasse écoute
ouais moi je m'en fous moi chacun fait
ce qu'il veut c'est ça
moi je suis un mec cool ouais tu juge
pas toi oh non non moi je m'en fous
chacun fait ce qu'il veut
ah suce
[Rires]
les violences conjugales là ils sont
tous les deux consentants ils sont
majeurs
communs voilà ils sortent très bien et
les messieurs qui gueule c'est les mêmes
qui coin divorce surpris une meuf de 20
ans de moins donc voilà je me demande si
c'était l'inverse si ce serait plus
choquant ou moins choquant par exemple
une comédienne très connue très riche un
peu âgé